Let's look at the answer to our atomic instruction quiz which asks, what do we
need to implement locks easily. An instruction that,
loads memory, stores to memory, or one that
reads and writes memory, or one that doesn't
access memory at all. We already, saw that
when either instruction does something like this, without
interference from others. So we the instruction that
atomically does this to operations. One is a read, one
is a write. So an instruction to just read's memory,
will not give us what we want. It's capable of
doing this, but it's not going to let us do
this. A store, might be able to do this, but
it can not first check the log variable to see
if it's available. So what we need really is an
instruction that both reads, and then writes the memory. And certainly
we don't need instruction that doesn't access memory because the lock
var is a memory location. So the correct answer is this.